est ce enfin le retour de schengen c'est
à dire la possibilité pour les voyageurs
européens de se déplacer librement dans
cet espace où les contrôles aux
frontières sont en temps normal abolie
et bien presque les critères communs
adopté par les ministres des affaires
européennes ce mardi veulent en tout cas
tendre vers ce monde d'avant premières
mesures une cartographie commune pour
définir les zones à risque au sein de
lieux
le texte prévoit que le centre européen
de prévention et de contrôle des
maladies publie chaque semaine une carte
de la situation de l'ensemble des pays
de l'union au niveau régional une carte
avec des codes couleur vert orange rouge
ou grise lorsque les données sont
insuffisantes pour classifier la zone en
question sont prises en compte le nombre
de nouveaux cas notifiés pour 100000
habitants sur les 14 derniers jours et
le taux de positivité déteste les
voyageurs venant d'une zone orange rouge
ou qu'ils peuvent se voir imposer à
l'arrivée une quarantaine et où un
dépistage ceux qui viennent d'une zone
verte ne sont soumis à aucune mesure il
ya un succès majeur qui sera acté
aujourd'hui c'est celui d'une
coordination des critères sanitaires
dans la lutte contre la colite 19 pour
que nous ayons les mêmes mesures partout
en europe les mêmes critères de décision
pour limiter les restrictions aux
déplacements préserver les déplacements
transfrontaliers
ils sont absolument essentielles et
donner de la visibilité
à nos citoyens à nos entreprises dans
cette période qui est déjà difficile
ce texte qui est une recommandation donc
sans contrainte ne fait pas l'unanimité
plusieurs pays se sont d'ailleurs
abstenus dont le luxembourg
son ministre des affaires étrangères
estime que le texte doit être je cite
complètes et approfondies en ajoutant
d'autres critères autres mesures
retenues celle de la reconnaissance
mutuelle des tests et des exemptions de
quarantaine pour les voyageurs exerçant
des fonctions jugé essentiel un
formulaire européen unique à remplir par
les voyageurs devraient également voir
le jour
reste à savoir si des états se plieront
à ces mesures sur la durée
eux qui n'ont pas pu se cordonner lors
des fermetures des frontières au
printemps et de leur réouverture durant
l'été